- I'm so excited you're here in person!
- I know, finally!
- Okay, I'm very excited.
I'm a lot. I'm a lot.
- We did it.
So am I, so am I.
- No, but I was so excited just
to get to interview the last time.
And I was like, "Oh my
God, she's in studio?
I'm so excited."
So you were in Europe
the last time, right?
- Yes, yes, and now we
get a taste of normality
and connectivity, I love it.
- Yeah!
And actually see people in person.
Well, last time, I think you live,
is it London, Paris, like.
- Yes.
- LA, you live everywhere.
Where's the best food?
- Oh, the best food.
I got to tell you, the French are good.
Not London. Sorry.
- I love that I didn't even
ask you which one's worse
and you were like, "I'm offering this up."
- But you know what?
They have some really
good international food.
Like Indian food.
- I like Indian food.
Yeah, Indian food there is good.
- Yeah, but the French are good.
- Yeah.
- Mexico is the best, but.
(audience cheers)
- I love Mexican food.
- You didn't put it in there.
- Yeah. I grew up in Texas.
So I grew up with TexMex,
which is different, but.
- We talked about it.
- We had authentic
and we had TexMex, I like both.
- Me too.
- But I will say,
the last one we talked about it,
it was tacos, you were
telling me the best tacos.
Where are the best tacos in LA,
if I wanted-
- My house.
My house.
- Fine.
I'll have to come taste them and hang out.
- I get very creative with the tacos.
- You love cooking?
- I love cooking,
I love cooking Mexican food.
And I love like, look at me.
Do you know,
I was going to that taco place
when I was like a little girl
and my house is the second
best place for tacos.
That place, (speaking foreign language)
is the best cochinita tacos in the world.
- You have the sexiest
voice on the planet.
- You have to teach you how to sing.
- Oh my God. If you can just, I tried.
Even upstairs, I was trying
to have your like rasp
and like your, and it's
just, it's so cool.
Anyway.
- Just work really hard
and don't sleep and you'll get to it
when you're in your fifties.
- I do that and I still sound
like a chipmunk.
- I'll come when you're
in your fifties, trust me.
- So wait, so wait, I didn't know this,
but I saw the pictures and
I guess you posted them.
You met Eminem, but you
accidentally spilled water on him?
How did that happen?
- Oh my God.
You see people don't,
I don't look like this happens to me,
but I have terrible stage fright.
- Oh!
- I'm just a really
good actress that I pretend
- Oh my gosh, you are.
- It's not happening, but
I really get it very bad.
Like I go just, my mouth gets dry.
And so I have a song
that I put in my head that
helps me get through it.
Which is-
- Please say it's Eminem.
- "Lose Yourself."
I mean, you hear that, you
feel like you can do anything,
right?
- That's true. That's true.
- So I hear it in my head.
And I was going to present at the Oscars,
which is really nerve wracking,
especially if you have stage fright.
- But when you're you,
that's crazy!
- I went like this, you know?
I could see my hearts coming.
- If I were you for one day,
I would never be nervous.
- Oh no!
I'm like, and then I come out like, "Hi!"
But I'm dying inside!
- You're a great actor!
- Yes, I am!
They should give me an
Oscar just for presenting
at the Oscars.
Just for presenting.
- That was a great acting job.
- And this one day, I was extra nervous
because I hadn't slept, I was jet lagged,
I was feeling shaky.
And so, this one time,
I'm drinking the water
because my mouth immediately goes dry.
- Yeah.
- Even with the water.
And I am thinking, I'm walking towards it,
in my head, thinking,
"Lose Yourself," you know.
I'm singing the song in my head.
And then I kind of feel like it's not
syncing to something.
And I am like drinking the water
and then I go,
wait a minute,
have I lost it?
I go to the person, "Is 'Lose
Yourself' playing right now?"
Because I heard it like in a stereo,
but he was not announced that
he was gonna be at the Oscars.
- Oh!
- As I was ready to come out,
he was on stage playing "Lose Yourself,"
but I didn't know.
- And surprised it.
- I knew everybody that was at the Oscars,
this was a surprise.
And so I am so nervous
that I think it's me
and then all of a sudden, wait a minute?
It was really scary
by the way.
- Wouldn't it have been great
though if everyone would have
been like, "I don't know what
you're talking about."
- No, I know!
- "I don't hear a thing."
- I was actually embarrassed
to ask, I hesitated for a
minute and it was the end of it.
And in this moment I'm like more nervous
and he comes out exactly
on the side that I am in.
And I just, I'm so nervous, I
go, "I love you! I love you!"
- You're shaking the water.
- I spit it out.
I was, I drank, and I said,
"I love you! I love you!"
- That goes so much worse!
Oh my God! Oh my God!
- I know!
And then I see that he's like,
in shock with water all over and I go,
- First of all.
- "I'm sorry! I'm sorry!"
And they're like, "Go! Go!"
"I'm sorry!"
And then they, they "Go, go!"
And I just, "Somebody take a picture!"
They took a picture and then I left.
- You both look terrified.
- I feel so humiliated.
I still had to go and do it
and the next day I went
home and I said, "Oh my God.
My hero thinks I'm a freak."
And the next morning they asked him,
because it was a big
deal, it was a surprise.
"Hey, did you enjoy going this time?"
Because when he won for
that song, he didn't go.
And he said something like,
"Oh, I really enjoyed it because
I got to meet Salma Hayek."
- Yeah, yeah! It was so cool.
(audience cheers)
I don't know if you know this,
but like a lot of people like you.
- But I spit on him!
- Kind of a big deal. Yeah.
You kind of might be an even
bigger deal than Eminem, so.
And I love Eminem.
- Well maybe,
he really looked very terrified.
- [Kelly] He did look
terrified, it's awesome.